final inspections for the sierra leone
flagship carrying ukrainian grain it's
heading to lebanon where there's been
food shortages and high prices for
months
russian ukrainian turkish and u.n
officials checked the cargo while the
ship docked in istanbul they're part of
the joint coordination center that was
set up here after a deal to resume
ukrainian grain exports last month
the most famine
uh
nation state uh with respect to the
grain shortage
shortage is lebanon
81
of
grains
uh depending on the ukrainian grains
carrying nearly 27 000 tons of corn the
ship departed the ukrainian port of
odessa on monday an estimated 20 million
tons of crane has been stuck in ukraine
since the start of war this ship behind
me is not the first commercial vessel to
transfer ukraine's trapped grains
throughout the five-month war but it's
also a sign the un-brokered grain deal
signed last month is working hundreds of
ships will now follow the same route and
method to export ukrainian grain and
fertilizer to its global food shortage
u.n and turkish officials hope the
agreement can lead to a ceasefire
between russia and ukraine
the vessel's journey along the newly
established maritime humanitarian
corridor in the black sea has been a
complex but historical achievement for
the joint coordination center
but for ukraine's president vladimir
zelinsky it's more complicated
[Applause]
thanks to the u.n partnership with
turkey we've had the first ship delivery
of grain but it's still nothing we hope
it's a tendency that will continue the
consequences of this war are horrible
not only for ukraine but for the world
now it's good to go for the ship
carrying critical food supplies it
crossed turkey's bus first straight and
heading towards the mediterranean
three ports in ukraine are due to resume
the export of millions more tons of
wheat corn and other crops cnm kosovo al
jazeera istanbul